there's a curiosity that this is serving
and it's to astrophysics for people in a
hurry that's kind of that's very
purposefully juxtaposed it's like
neurosurgery in four easy steps you know
if you saw a book with that title you
have to pick up wonder what's going on
well not to kiss your ass again but I
always say this about you and I think
it's important you make learning stuff
about astrophysics fun and that's what's
missing you know it's not that people
don't like to be educated that they
don't like to learn they just don't want
to be bored
that's a perceptive point because you
know think of the image we have of let's
say you're in a school where most people
don't go to college if you're in high
school and then last day of school comes
what do people do they toss their papers
in the air as they run down the steps
school's out no but what's the rock song
[Music]
forever right so that attitude must mean
the school didn't train you to embrace
curiosity right that learning was a
chore and now the chores are over yeah
so I think the educational system needs
an adjustment forget whether or not you
go to college because you're gonna spend
more years not in school than in school
even if you do go to college what you
want I think are lifelong learners
lifelong curiosity yes where once you
are trained and and and and and your
curiosity is stimulated the curiosity
we've all had as children your children
don't need to be taught to be curious
they are curious to the point of
destruction of whatever it is they touch
oh what is this egg on the counter
what is this glass what is this plate
what's under a rock what happens when I
pull a leg off a daddy long you know
they are experimenting with the world we
don't think of it that way but that's
what it is they're all born scientists
and I say this often you spend the first
years of a child's life teaching it to
walk and talk then he spend the rest of
his life telling it to shut up and sit
it's this this is the wrong combination
so speaking as an educator I think a
missing component of school is
is that the teachers is that the
curriculum I don't know but when you get
out of school you should say to yourself
damn I want to learn more
it's almost universally accepted to that
that's when you're learning ends when
you get out of college it's over you say
you're done and if it doesn't you're
ossified in line and that's how when the
job market shifts you're not ready for
it because you don't know how to think
you don't know how to learn right and
it's the difference in the in the
workplace between the person who gets an
assignment I Joey Janet I need you to do
this that's not in my job description
I'm not trained for this that's one kind
of person in a workplace another kind of
person is here's a new task I need you
to do wow I've never seen that before
great let me figure it out right he's a
two completely different species of
human being and what the world needs
more of is like the the second case
where you take a new task and you say
wow I get to learn I'm gonna learn on my
own I'll ask people who know more you
just you just embrace the act of
learning to satisfy your curiosity and I
think this book is capturing that in the
public I must be doing something yeah
yeah 60 how many weeks 67 week yeah yeah
that's a lot of weeks yeah every morning
I wake up I'm I'm calm but I'm really
not calm I'm saying holy [ __ ]
sorry you're alive I can't can I say you
can say [ __ ] I could say that's where
human people think you're a robot now
they know this is it's a great sign I
think and I think your podcast is a
great sign as well the success of your
podcast and success of a lot of science
podcasts that's excellent you notice
that there's a rise of science curious
podcasts out there stuff to blow your
mind is one that I really enjoy right I
really love radio lab they've always got
elaborate interesting science to the
annual perennial favorite that so many
peopre obably the best right yeah and
and yours as well and I love Chuck nice
shout out to Chuck nice well Chuck we
listen to all of Chuck he's great but
what you're doing is you're making
learning interesting and that's why it's
so fun it's it's it's it's there's
excitement to it and you bring a
comedian like Chuck on with you things
get silly but they're also curious and
you're getting these experts and
everyone's talking about these various
subjects and
and as you know not only yourself as an
exemplar of this stand-up comedians are
some of the smartest people in the world
they have it that they ever knew well
you know that far come to the comedy
store with me today I'll change your
mind so stand-up comedians are
perceptive people yes and for sure and
they're aware and they notice things
that you don't notice they see the same
things you do and get to shape it in a
way you never thought possible and then
you end up laughing at other things at
yourself was